[Music]  buildings in the next 50 years will have  a very big impact on the environment  the paradox of the next year will be in  one side we want to reduce emission to  zero the emission of co2  and on the other side we need to build  billions of square meters  [Music]  decline is the first experiment of a  house  building in clay through the wasp  company  so we we matching the idea of an old  material we will mix  with the new technology 3d printing and  creating  house in clay maybe the future is also  to look our path  and discovery the knowledge we are lost  in the last 250 years  maybe the next cities where we would  like to be  the smart city green city zero to a  mission city is a  city in clay but mixing digital  and old material